[Musik]
[Applaus]
Mantra von Amazon.com und seinem
stürmischen Gründer Jeff Bezos von dem
Moment an als ich dort anfing haben wir
das Gaspedal immer stärker durchgetreten
der kühne Unternehmer hat die Regeln des
Handels neu geschrieben
alle hatten es eilig bei der oberen des
Internets die der stattfand wissen sie
etablieren wir die Marke Amazon ist
seine Strategie zahlte sich nicht immer
aus auch nach dem Börsengang haben sich
die Leute die Finanzdaten angeguckt und
gesagt die werden das nicht schaffen
Amazon.com war im Dezember 95
tatsächlich profitabel
ungefähr für eine Stunde mit klaren
Schachzügen baute Jeff Bezos Amazon.com
auf und um wenn du eine Frage stellst
auf die Jeff nicht wirklich eingehen
will dann ist die Antwort die du kriegst
ein Lachen
und lachend hat er jede Menge Geld
gemacht
auf Amazon kannst du alles kaufen from
Box Bücher Musik Schuhe bis hin zu
Kampfpanzern oder Tiki Hütten Amazon ist
der erfolgreichste Online-Händler der
Welt
und wird immer noch von dem Mann geführt
der ihn gegründet hat Jeff Bezos
der einzige Ort zu sein an dem man
praktisch alles kaufen kann was auf dem
Einzelhandelsmarkt erhältlich ist es war
ein entscheidender Teil der
Wachstumsstrategie des Unternehmens
das öffentliche Bild von Jeff Bezos ist
das eine Superhelden und das ist er er
ist Risiken eingegangen er hat Probleme
gelöst und er hat Milliarden von Dollar
an Vermögen angehäuft als Privatperson
ist basos zurückhaltender als in der
Öffentlichkeit und er lehnte es ab an
unserem Programm teilzunehmen
Jeffrey Preston basos wurde am 12 januar
1964 in elbuquerquey New Mexico geboren
als Sohn von Jackie Geiss einer
17-Jährigen Gymnasiastin Geiss ließ sich
von seinem leiblichen Vater scheiden und
heiratete Miguel basos einen kubanischen
Einwanderer und Exon
erdölingenieurte das vierjährige Kind
basos beschrieb seine frühen
computererfahrungen 2001 in einem
Interview mit der Academy of a chiefmünd
Houston hat dieser kleinen Grundschule
Großrechner geliehen
keiner der Lehrer wusste wie man die
Computer bedient niemand wusste das
aber es gab einen Stapel Handbücher und
ich und ein paar andere Kinder blieben
nach dem Unterricht und lernten wie man
dieses Ding programmiert
[Musik]
zum ersten Mal als Unternehmer mit einem
Sommercamp mit den Schwerpunkten
Wissenschaft und Literatur
fünf Studenten meldeten sich an für 150
Dollar pro Kopf
1986 schloss er sein Elektrotechnik und
Informatikstudium an der printston
University wird Sommer cum laude ab
Nicolas Carlson ist Redakteur bei
Business insider.com und berichtet seit
sechs Jahren über Amazon Jeff Bezos
bekam einen Job bei einem hedgefondamen
stea er wollte nicht im Finanzwesen
arbeiten sondern als
Computerprogrammierer und die Show war
genau das der hedgefondbasierte auf
Algorithmen und der Art von Technologie
für die sich bessers interessierte
es war nicht das einzige das ihn
interessiert hat er stieß auf eine
Statistik die ihn überraschte dass das
Internet pro Jahr um 2.300% wuchs er war
einfach besessen von dieser Zahl
sich die 20 größten Versandhändler an
und witterte seine Chance im Internet
Chris Anderson damals Chefredakteur des
Magazins wired hier er sah diesen
technologischen Tsunami kommen der ganz
neue Vertriebskanäle schaffen würde er
würde die Wirtschaft neu definieren und
die Art und Weise ändern wie wir kauften
und verkauften
die Frage war in welchem Bereich sollten
wir das Anwenden die Antwort waren
Bücher eine wahre für die es keinen
umfassenden Katalog gab
im Juli 1994 kündigte er seinen sicheren
Job an der Wallstreet um seinen Traum zu
verwirklichen einer der ersten
Online-Buchhandlungen der Welt
seine ersten Investoren waren seine
Eltern
die erste Frage meines Vaters war was
ist das Internet
nicht auf die Firma oder das Konzept
gewettet er hat doch sein Sohn gerettet
im Sommer 94 machten sich basos und
seine Frau Mackenzie auf den Weg in den
Stadt Washington bewaffnet mit 300
Dollar von seinen Eltern die
technologie-expertin Esther Dyson ist
Vorsitzende der Investmentfirma
Adventure Holdings
es gibt viele Leute die die Wallstreet
verlassen um eigene Start-ups zu gründen
aber Jeff war anders er hatte viel
Erfahrung gesammelt und dann hat er
etwas Erstaunliches geschaffen in Danny
created something Basis und seine Frau
ließen sich in Bellevue Washington
nieder und stellten zwei Programmierer
eins erzählte darüber in einer Rede am
Lake forest College
ich fand ein Haus das als Geschäft
dienen könnte es hat eine Garage das
passte es gibt doch all diese
Geschichten von Startups und Garagen ne
das war nicht ganz legitim weil es eine
umfunktionierte anbaugarage war aber sie
war nicht isoliert es waren wirklich
keine beeindruckenden Büros
er nannte die Firma Amazon nach dem
scheinbar endlosen Fluss in Südamerika
mit seinen unzähligen Nebenflüssen
am 16 juli 95 öffnete Amazon.com seine
virtuellen Türen
James markus war Mitarbeiter Nummer 55
er sollte damals Buchbesprechungen
schreiben die nichts weiter als eine
Liste von Titeln bei als ich mir die
Website angeguckt habe um zu sehen ob
ich da wirklich arbeiten will stellte
ich fest wie rudimentärse war es gab
eine Titelseite mit einer bunten
Mischung von Büchern aber das
bemerkenswerteste war es gab einen
riesigen Katalog mit mehreren
hunderttausend Titeln der aber gar
keinen Inhalt hatte
Amazon.com hatte kein Werbebudget die
ersten Umsätze wurden ausschließlich
über Mundpropaganda erzählt
he is Terry Geschäftsführer bei Goldman
Sachs
es war wirklich von Anfang an ganz
anders bei Amazon sie waren nicht in
Silicon Valley sie waren in Seattle und
sie haben auch bei diesen ganzen Hype
nicht mitgemacht und jeden Tag
Pressemitteilungen rausgegeben
doch die Seite setzte sich durch
innerhalb eines Monats hatte Amazon
Kunden in allen 50 Bundesstaaten und 45
weiteren Ländern
gut geführt er war organisiert er
verstand den Vertrieb
des Menschen zum Kaufen zu motivieren
mit viel Liebe zum Detail
besus Ziel könnte in einer einfachen
Zeile zusammengefasst werden
Mantra und auch eine strategische
Entscheidung alles musste gedopt sein
das ganze Wachstum musste gedopt sein
Eric best war von 1999 bis 2001 Manager
für Geschäftsentwicklung bei Amazon
Marktanteile zu kommen
wie können wir die Marke Amazon
etablieren und das Geschäft ausbauen
innerhalb eines sehr kleinen
Zeitfensters
die Strategie zahlt es sich aus
Ende 1996 hatte das Unternehmen einen
Umsatz von 15,7 Millionen Dollar die
Gewinne wurden dadurch gesteigert dass
Amazon den meisten Kunden steuerfreies
Einkaufen anbaut
was uns ausmacht ist die große Auswahl
und der Komfort wir liefern direkt bis
zur Haustür und wir sind der größte
Discounter der Welt wir bieten über
300.000 Titel die meistverkauften Titel
das sind doppelt so viele wie die größte
physische Buchhandlung anbieten kann
[Musik]
aber die Investoren waren frustriert der
umsatzsteg ohne Gewinne Amazon gab
Millionen aus um Software zu entwickeln
und das Geschäft auszubauen
das Unternehmen ging in dieser Zeit
viele Risiken ein und ich glaube es gab
viele Spekulationen darüber dass das
Richtige war oder nicht
jetzt ist es leicht zurückzublicken und
zu sagen sie mussten so viel investieren
um diese Größe zu erreichen die sie
heute haben
aber das war nicht vom ersten Tag an
klar
klar war das basos nicht aufzuhalten war
er hielt das Tempo durch und trieb den
Börsengang von Amazon voran die Idee war
dass man sich nicht einen Moment auf
seinen Lorbeeren ausruht dass man
einfach ständig innovativ sein und sich
von der Konkurrenz fernhalten muss und
keine Millisekunde lang selbstgefällig
ist
am 15 Mai 97 wurde die Aktie an der
messtechbörse zu einem Preis von 29
Dollar 25 pro Aktie gehandelt fast 12
Dollar über den Ausgabepreis
der Tag des eigentlichen Börsengangs war
eine echt große Sache
überall in der Firma gab es Partys Jeff
rief uns aus New York an und sagte wir
haben heute Geschichte geschrieben ihr
habt alle heute Geschichte geschrieben
es war verdammt aufregend
aber trotz des gelungenen Börsengangs
hatten tech-analysten immer noch so ihre
Zweifel
ist Gründer und CEO von O'Reilly Media
damals dachten viele dass Amazon
untergehen würde sie nahmen die Finanzen
genau unter die Lupe und sagten dieses
Unternehmen wird nie profitabel sein es
gab viele nein Sager Amazon arbeitete
hart daran die Webseite zu aktualisieren
und Funktionen wie one clickshopping
einzuführen
Ende 97 hat sich der Aktienwert fast
verdreifacht
Jeff sagte damals achte nicht auf den
Aktienkurs er war zuversichtlich dass er
auf lange Sicht immer weiter steigen
würde aber erhielt es für sehr
gefährlich ihn kurzfristig zu betrachten
Amazon setzte seine rasante Expansion
fort stellte über 7.000 Mitarbeiter ein
und verstärkte seine Produktpalette
wir haben über praktisch alles geredet
wir könnten Lebensmittel verkaufen
Hygieneartikel Handys und Handytarife
Zeitschriften und auch Hardware
Gartenschläuche und Spielzeug das
größere Angebot und der hohe
absatzzahlten sich aus für Amazon.com
als auch für Basics
am 20 Dezember 99 wurde er vom time
Magazin zur Person des Jahres gekürt
meine Mutter hat geweint Eltern sind
immer stolz das fühlt sich toll an es
war die ultimative Bestätigung seines
Traums die Welt mit E-Commerce zu wenn
sie durch das Magazin Blättern sehen Sie
Jeff als Indiana Jones der an einer
Liane schwingt es machte ihn in gewisser
Weise zu einem amerikanischen
Volkshelden es ist als hätte Paul
Bananen den Flur runter sein Büro
war ganz oben angekommen bis eine
Katastrophe die ganze Branche
erschütterte
Ende der 90er Jahre war Amazon eine
internet-dampfwalze aber im Jahr 2000
platzte die Blase die Aktienkurse
brachen ein und Jeff Bezos war zu
drastischen Maßnahmen gezwungen
es gab zwei Entlassungswellen und wie so
oft weiß man nicht wer gehen muss man
kauert in seinem Büro und wartet darauf
dass die Personalabteilung kommt und mit
dem Finger auf jemanden zeigt und es tut
weh Kollegen gehen zu sehen
Kontext angesichts des Rückgangs der
Wirtschaft und des Verbrauchervertrauens
war dass die einzig vernünftige
Entscheidung die wir treffen konnten
im September 2001 erreichte die Aktie
des Unternehmens ein Allzeittief mit
fünf Dollar 97
vom Aushängeschild zum Prügelknaben in
einer Sekunde es ist nicht die Art von
Aktie die man besitzt und dann gut
schläft wenn man ein kleiner Investor
ist das gilt übrigens für alle
Internetaktien
der Vorteil den Amazon hatte war sie
hatte sich sozusagen diese Kriegskasse
angelegt um sowas finanzieren zu können
davon
Jeff Bezos hat hoch gewettet aber nicht
alle Wetten haben sich ausgezahlt am
Anfang hat das Unternehmen lange keinen
Profit gemacht der Grund warum Jeff
Bezos damit durchkam war dass er immer
direkt mit seinen Mitarbeitern und den
anteilseigern war
im Januar 2002 begannen sich die Wetten
endlich auszuzahlen
der Aktienkurs erholte sich und nach
sieben Jahren machte basos Unternehmen
endlich wieder gewinnen
das Beste was ich über ihn sagen kann
ist seine unerschütterliche Zuversicht
er wusste dass die Skeptiker zu
kurzfristig dachten sie sahen nicht das
große Ganze und er hielt immer an seiner
Vision fest
wie als die Blase geplatzt war hatten
die Investoren keine Geduld mehr für
Unternehmen die sagten wir investieren
in den Aufbau einer dotcom-seite in
unserem Geschäft
das nutzte Amazon aus und arbeitete mit
target und Toys R Us und gäb und anderen
Einzelhändlern zusammen
der internethandelsriese tatsächlich mit
mehr als 400 Unternehmen zusammen aber
nicht alle Einzelhändler waren billige
Partner ich kenne eine Reihe von Fällen
in denen er Unternehmen erworben hat um
potentielle zukünftige Wettbewerber
auszuschalten und nicht weil er deren
Geschäft wirklich weiterführen wollte
nachdem sein Unternehmen wieder auf Kurs
war konzentrierte sich basos auf eine
ganz andere Leidenschaft
am 6 märz 2003 schatterte er einen
Helikopter um sich abgelegene Gegenden
in Texas anzuschauen
er wollte Grundstücke kaufen für Blue
Origin ein Technologieunternehmen das er
im Jahr 2000 gegründet hatte um
senkrecht Start und senkrecht Lande
Raketen für die bemannte Raumfahrt zu
entwickeln
die Reise endete fast in einer
Katastrophe kurz nach dem Start geriet
der Helikopter ins Trudeln und landete
in einem Flussbett
[Musik]
2003 starb Jeff Bezos fast bei einem
Hubschrauberabsturz es ist wie ein
Muster er macht etwas Schlimmes durch
wie einen internetcrash und dann
philosophiert er darüber und lacht es
einfach weg
im Gegensatz zu space exploration
Ventures das von privaten Geldgebern wie
Elon Musk Richard Branson und John
Carmack finanziert wird ist basos
besessen davon blue Origin geheim zu
halten
es war aus verschiedenen Gründen
ziemlich geheimnisvoll und aus Sicht der
Raumfahrtindustrie ist das eigentlich
schade was ein guten Markt ausmacht ist
wenn ein Haufen Konkurrenten offen
miteinander konkurriert und versucht
sich gegeneinander zu positionieren sie
konkurrieren um Geld sie konkurrieren um
Menschen und so weiter
nach sechs Jahren arbeitende
verschlossenen Türen hob die seltsam
aussehende testrakete von Blue Origin
endlich ab
[Applaus]
und Bezos war dabei einen weiteren
revolutionären Versuch zu starten
diesmal weniger weit weg
das war eine Gelegenheit die Buchbranche
enorm zu erweitern und die Definition
dessen was ein Buch sein kann aber es
brauchte jemanden mit ausreichend
Schlagkraft um diese Zusammenführung von
Hardware und Software durchzuführen
nur amazon war in der Lage das zu tun
am 19 November 2007 nahm Bezos an der
Charlie Rose Show teil und kündigte ein
bahnbrechendes neues Produkt an
ich halte hier in Händen wovon wir reden
es heißt Kindle sagen Sie mir wann Sie
zum ersten Mal auf die Idee kam dass so
etwas möglich sein würde
und zwar klar geworden dass es einige
Technologien gab die irgendwie zusammen
liefen und dass wir mit dem richtigen
Rezept etwas erschaffen konnten von dem
wir hofften dass es die Welt des
elektronischen Lesens verändern würde
der Kindle war sofort ein Hit amazon hat
dieses Gerät auf den Markt gebracht dem
so viele der ästhetischen Vorteile von
echten Büchern fehlten du kannst die
Seiten nicht mehr riechen keine
Eselsohren mehr reinmachen aber all die
Buchliebhaber die dieses Ding gefürchtet
haben lieben es jetzt
der 399 Dollar teure E-Reader war in nur
fünfeinhalb Stunden ausverkauft
die genauen Verkaufszahlen bleiben
allerdings ein streng gehütetes
Geheimnis vom Unternehmen heißt es man
wolle sie nicht veröffentlichen
und ist Mitbegründerin von open-road
integrated Media
niemand weiß wie viele Kindles es
wirklich gibt es ist ein Ratespiel wir
wissen dass es Millionen gibt aber wie
viele Millionen aber es ist
offensichtlich die Strategie von Amazon
sie halten viele Informationen unter
Verschluss
aber für viele Verlage war der Kindle
ein branchenkiller
es wird in den nächsten Jahren echtes
Blut im Verlagswesen fließen weil die
Verlage nicht früh genug bemerkt haben
dass Amazon ein Konkurrent ist
[Musik]
während der Kindle große Wellen auf dem
e-book-mark schlug bereitete Amazon
seine bisher größte
unternehmensakquisition vor
Tony Shay ist CEO von seppos.com
Americas führendem online-schuhhändler
als ich 2004 Jeff Bezos zum ersten Mal
traf sagte er sei dran interessiert
serpos zu kaufen
donnerstagten wir werden kein Interesse
als ein Professoren wie seine Identität
verlieren würde
an Amazon zu verkaufen Dave sie haben
sich wieder bei uns gemeldet und gesagt
dass sie sich auch vorstellen könnten
dass wir unabhängig bleiben
und uns wurde klar das könnten wirklich
großartige Partner sein wie Roli Gray
Partners im Sommer 2009 kaufte Amazon
den angesagten online-schuhhändler
hielten 10 Millionen Amazon Aktien im
Wert von rund 1,2 Milliarden Dollar
sie bekamen Aktien die zu diesem
deutlich besser als Bargeld waren und
das zeigt dass Jeff Bezos jemand ist der
die Konkurrenz überrollen kann wenn es
sein muss der aber auch bereit ist zu
verhandeln und zu bekommen was er will
und dabei aber alle reicher zu machen
der Schuh passte aber sein Goldesel der
Kindle bekam ernsthafte Konkurrenz von
einem technologie-riesen
am 27 januar 2010 brachte Apple das iPad
auf den Markt das auch als e-lesegerät
konzipiert
wars reagierte aggressiv senkte die
Kosten und fügte seinem E-Reader neue
Funktionen hinzu eine Sache die besseres
als Amazon-Chef schon immer gerne getan
hat ist das Spielen mit sehr engen
Margen die Preissenkung des Kindle zeigt
dass bessers erkannt hatte wo der
wirklich langfristige Gewinn für Amazon
liegt
nämlich der Anbieter zu sein wo jeder
seine Bücher kauft und der Kindle ist
das Gerät mit dem man sie bekommt
das phänomenale Wachstum des
e-bookmaklers ruinierte viele
Bücherläden
Amazon kam auf die Bühne und wurde zum
Konkurrenten der Einzelhändler sie waren
jetzt der e-händler
das Unternehmen borders hätte ihr
Untergang sein können aber der
Buchhändler hat seinen gesamten
digitalen Verkauf über Amazon
abgewickelt hätte er seine eigene
Präsenz aufgebaut wäre die Situation
heute vielleicht ganz anders present
sind meine very differen Situation
nach Angaben der autoreninnung kaufte
Amazon Bücher in Großhandel für 12 bis
13 Dollar und verkaufte sie als
kindelbücher für 9,99 €. machte also
jedes Mal Verlust
Bestsellerautor John Grisham wetterte
gegen dieses Preismodell
Wert ist sei es ein preisreduziertes
Hardcover bei Amazon oder eine E-Book
für den Kindle wenn wir jetzt bei 10
Dollar sind dann wird sich die ganze
Branche verändern wir werden Verlage
verlieren wir werden Buchhandlung
verlieren
andere sahen darin eine Gelegenheit
sehen sie sich all die Autoren an die
durch den Kindle die Möglichkeit bekam
eine direkte Kundenbeziehung aufzubauen
ich glaube das macht Amazon zum Gewinner
des ganzen weil sie eine Brücke zwischen
Autoren und Lesern gebaut haben die es
bisher so nicht gegeben hat
[Musik]
Insolvenz an und auch bahns and noble
die größte Buchhandelskette hatte zu
kämpfen
2011 stieg Amazon.com außerdem in den
Videos Streaming Markt ein
und trat damit gegen Netflix an Andrew
wollensteam ist tv-redakteur für das
Magazin the rialty
ich glaube wenn sie Netflix sind sehen
sie in Amazon einen echten Konkurrenten
amazon hat online viel Anziehungskraft
sie haben tiefe Taschen um genauso viele
Titel zu kaufen sie stehen hier zwar
noch ganz am Anfang aber mit der Zeit
könnte Amazon genauso groß werden wie
Netflix
doch der Internet-Riese ist mit
wachsendem Widerstand gegen seinen
unversteuerten Online-Umsatz
konfrontiert
mehrere Staaten verlangen lokale
Umsatzsteuern
zeigt sich unbeeindruckt und mach
weiteres hat seine Finger in
jedermannskuchen er hat video streaming
das mit Netflix konkurriert er macht
Musik die mit Apple und iTunes
konkurriert er rückt sogar mit einem
eigenen AppStore Google auf die Pelle
sieht mit dem Amazon ein bisschen Geld
verdienen und seinen dünnen Margen
helfen kann dann würde es tun
er hat es weit gebracht und sein
weltraumprojekt sogar noch weiter
im April 2011 bekam blue Origin 22
Millionen Dollar von der NASA für die
Entwicklung seines Raumfahrzeugs
Bloomberg setzt auf Platz 20 der
reichsten Menschen der Welt mit einem
geschätzten Nettovermögen von 25
Milliarden Dollar
Amazon.com bleibt der weltweit größte
Online-Händler er ist nicht nur ein
Visionär er ist ein Architekt mit Plänen
und einer Vorstellung davon wie man
Dinge zum Laufen bringt er denkt sehr
sorgfältig über design-struktur und
Betrieb nach und das macht aus einem
Visionär jemanden der tatsächlich etwas
leistet
er hätte Amazon an barns and nobel oder
an andere Buchhändler verkaufen und
viele Millionen Dollar machen können
sowie mit Anfang 30 seitdem
kommt er immer wieder mit richtig guten
Ideen
er ist nicht der harte Typ der über
Leichen geht er ist jemand der seine
Vision hat wie er dieses Unternehmen
aufbauen möchte und er ist in der Lage
sich mit Leuten zu umgeben die sich
darauf einlassen ich denke dass es
letztendlich einer der Gründe warum er
so erfolgreich ist
[Musik]
retastings scheint so zäh zu sein wie
seine DVDs praktisch unverwüstlich er
hat die Welt des Films und des
Fernsehens verändert
zweimal wir vermieten DVDs zum
Pauschalpreis ganz einfach er ist einer
der Leute die die Videotheken getötet
haben
werden nichts lieber getan als Netflix
abzuwehren er trotzte seinen Kritikern
und setzte auf Filme per Post als DVDs
noch eine Neuheit waren die meisten
Investoren dachten das Netflix nur ein
weiteres dot com ist eine kleine Nischen
Idee dass die Leute kein Abo wollen und
es sich nie durchsetzen wird
es setzte sich durch sein Wert steht
innerhalb von zwölf Jahren auf 12
Milliarden Dollar Syrien bis ein fataler
Fehler das Wachstum stoppte Netflix
Abonnenten flüchten massenhaft mehr als
800.000 Kunden haben im letzten Quartal
gekündigt einige Leute sagten es wäre
als hätten Aliens die Macht über seinen
Körper übernommen Hastings ist
entschlossen den Ruf seines Unternehmens
wiederherzustellen ähm
er kommt wie ein typischer Silicon
Valley Manager rüber sehr zurückhaltend
aber er ist einer von denen die gewinnen
müssen
zwölf Jahren als wir mit Netflix
angefangen haben lief das Internet noch
über AOL Einwahl aber
es wurde klar hey die Netzwerke werden
wachsen und alle Videos werden Click &
watch videos im Internet alle
retastings machte Karriere indem er die
Zukunft vorhersah zuerst mit einem
Software-Tool dann mit einer einfachen
DVD und einer 32 Cent Briefmarke sie
werden niemanden finden der mehr Antrieb
hat als retasting er denkt ständig über
die nötigen strategischen Veränderungen
nach
hier er ist ein unglaublich
zielstrebiger innovativer Mensch der so
klug ist wie
unfassbar klug einfach
einer dieser Typen die nicht gerne viel
über sich selbst reden
aber er glaubt dass seine Taten zeigen
wie gut er ein Unternehmen führen kann
getreu diesen Motto wollte er auch mit
uns nicht über sich selbst reden
Hastings wurde 1960 in
boston-massachusetts geboren und wuchs
im Vorort belmond auf der ehemalige
Gouverneur great Davis ist ein Freund
von Hastings er stammt aus der
Mittelschicht sein Vater war Anwalt die
Familie war nicht sehr wohlhabend
Bildung war der Grund für seinen Erfolg
dazu gehörte ein Bachelorabschluss am
Boden College in Maine
er verbrachte einen Sommer in einem
Ausbildungsprogramm der US-Marine
erkannte aber dass das Militär nichts
für ihn war er trat dem friedenskorb bei
unterrichtete zwei Jahre lang und
trämmte dann mit 10 Dollar in der Tasche
durch Afrika
das Unterrichten inspirierte ihn die Art
Charlie Rose 2005 erzählte
also ich war Highschool Mathelehrer im
friedenskorb und Swasiland und ich liebe
das Unterrichten ich habe High School
Mathe unterrichtet und das war einfach
eine fantastische Erfahrung als er in
die USA zurückkehrte machte er in
Stanford seinen Master in Informatik und
bekam eine Stelle bei dem
Technologieunternehmen deptive
Corporation markbox ist ein
start-up-investor der Hastings zu Beginn
einer neuen Ära der Computer
Programmierung kennenlernte
er sagte wissen sie bis jetzt entstand
jedes Programm das erstellt wurde im
Wesentlichen im Kopf einer Person
aber jetzt kommen wir an den Punkt an
den zwei drei fünf zehn Leute ein
Programm schreiben müssen und wenn das
passiert gibt es Probleme bei der
Koordination zwischen den Leuten und das
führt zu vielen Fehlern
Fehler von denen Hastings glaubte sie
beheben zu können er schrieb ein
Programm und gründete mit markbox die
Firma pure Software wie alle
Perfektionisten wollte Hastings die
besten einstellen und hat alles um sie
zu bekommen
ich wollte die Firma bei der ich war
nicht verlassen aber dann kam er mit
einem Sixpack Bier in meine Wohnung und
wir fingen an zu reden das ist seine
typische Art
Audrey McLaine war eine von Hastings
Essen Investoren und ein
Vorstandsmitglied sobald wir loslegten
gab es keinen Halten mehr das Geschäft
verdoppelte sich jedes Jahr vier Jahre
in Folge eine richtige Rakete
1995 hatte pure Software den heiligen
Gral der Start-ups erreicht dem
Börsengang am Eröffnungstag schossen die
Aktien um 75% in die
höhegend 1995 waren wir für eine Woche
der erfolgreichste Börsengang des Jahres
in der Woche danach ging Netscape an die
Börse und stellte alles in den Schatten
der Erfolg brachte Hastings auf die
Titelseite von USA Today vor seinem
auffälligen neuen Porsche Carrera ein
Foto das er später bereuen sollte Cliff
Edwards technologie-reporter bei
Bloomberg Business Week
er hatte das Gefühl dass er wie eine Art
Reiches Wunder kennt dargestellt wurde
dass sein Traum lebt obwohl er
eigentlich zeigen wollte dass er ein
Unternehmen hat sehr gesund pflegt und
dass er sein Leben steckt
zwei Jahre später verkaufte er das
Unternehmen für 750 Millionen Dollar und
richtete seinen Blick ganz woanders hin
Michael Cast ist irritierter Professor
für Pädagogik an der Stanford University
ich bekam einen Anruf von jemandem von
dem ich noch nie gehört hatte retastings
der sagte er wolle nach Stanford kommen
und Bildungspolitik studieren ich war
mir nicht ganz sicher warum er daran
interessiert war denn es passt hier
nicht zu seinem Lebenslauf
[Musik]
sechs Monate lang studierte er und
versuchte dann sich für eine neue Art
von Schule in Kalifornien einzusetzen
und es gelang ihm eines der ersten
Gesetze für Schulen in freier
Trägerschaft durchzusetzen das
Innovation und neue Betreiber zuließ und
ein völlig neues Konzept für Kalifornien
war
[Musik]
auch für Hastings gab es ein neues
Konzept ein Vorfall 1997 brachte ihn
dazu eine ganze Branche neu zu erfinden
bei Charlie Rose erinnerte er sich 2005
an eine 40 dollar-säumnisgebühr die er
an einen Filmverleih zahlen musste
ich weiß noch dass ich meiner Frau
nichts davon erzählen wollte und dachte
oh toll jetzt setze ich schon meine Ehe
deswegen aufs Spiel als er erzählte ich
ihr natürlich davon
dann dachte ich ich kann doch nicht der
Einzige sein der mit solchen
säumnisgebühren zu kämpfen hat dann
dachte ich über das Internet und DVDs
nach darüber wie das auch ohne
funktionieren könnte
die filmverleihbranche machte rund 8
Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr
fast alles davon mit VHS-Kassetten die
Sets Hastings sah die Chance in einem
neuen Format und einem überraschenden
neuen Geschäft DVDs per Post aber zuerst
musste er herausfinden ob die Scheiben
den Postweg überleben würden
CDs eingepackt DVDs konnten sie noch
nicht kaufen und habe sie an mich selbst
geschickt und musste dann erstmal 24
Stunden warten um zu sehen ob sie in
Stücke zerbrochen sind zusammen mit
meiner Idee und dann am nächsten Tag um
3 Uhr kam der Post heute und ich riss
die Umschläge auf und die erste sah gut
aus die zweite sah gut aus die dritte
sah gut aus und ich dachte mir dieser
Blödsinn wird funktionieren
1998 startete Hastings Netflix als
ersten
online-dvd-verleih DVD der heutige
redbox-präsident mit slow war einer der
Mitgründer
wir begannen in einem datenbankgebäude
unser Inventar hatten wir in einem alten
Tresorraum wir waren vielleicht sieben
acht Leute und jeder wollte herausfinden
wie man das Unterhaltungsgeschäft
umkrempeln könnte
sie deckten sich bei Einzelhändlern wie
BestBuy mit DVDs ein aber es gab ein
Problem
kaum ein Haushalt hatte einen
DVD-Spieler DVD Player sie kosteten fast
600 Dollar und niemand wusste wann sie
billiger werden würden er hat alles auf
die DVDs gesetzt wenn es die DVDs nicht
gegeben hätte die Firma wäre nichts
einfach null
[Musik]
Blockbuster und Hollywood Video
beherrschten die Branche mit tausenden
von Einzelhandelsgeschäften fast überall
dann Hastings konkurrenzfähig sein
wollte musste er sich etwas einfallen
lassen
und er hatte eine Idee dir ein einfach
zu bedienendes Abo gegen eine monatliche
Gebühr konnten die Mitglieder so viele
Filme sehen wie sie wollten ohne seines
Gebühren
erkannte dass es keine gute Idee ist den
Kunden jedes Mal eine Rechnung über 3
Dollar zu stellen also brachte er das
Unternehmen dazu ein Abo-Modell
einzuführen und das hat alles verändert
diese Veränderung wurde durch zwei neue
Funktionen begünstigt die Warteliste für
Filme die die Nutzer sehen wollten und
computergenerierte Empfehlungen die
erstaunlich genau waren Michael patter
verfolgt Netflix seit zehn Jahren als
research Analyst bei webbush Securitys
der Internet bestellmechanismus war
innovativ die empfehlungsmaschine war
innovativ und die Warteschlange war
innovativ Netflix war schon sehr früh
Königreich weil sie die ersten waren die
all diese Dinge herausgefunden haben
aber trotz aller Innovationen war
Netflix immer noch kaum auf dem Radar
die Einnahmen von 5 Millionen Euro
Anfang 2000 verschwanden neben den 4,5
Milliarden von Blockbuster die 900 mal
so groß waren wie Netflix
in einem cleveren Zug hing Hastings auf
seinen größten Konkurrenten zu alle
liebten Blockbuster sorgbasta war das
goldene Kind und Netflix war so etwas
wie das hässliche Stiefkind das da jetzt
kam und alle dachten nun das Ding wird
nicht überleben dem werden keine Beine
wachsen es wird sterben wir hatten
Probleme Kunden zu akquirieren und wir
sahen Blockbuster als größte
einzelquelle für verleihkunden
also warten wir uns an Sie und luden sie
einen strategischer Partner und Investor
zu werden
john andirco war Geschäftsführer von
Blockbuster als Netflix auftauchte
wir dachten naja wenn wir in dieses
Geschäft einsteigen sollten wir die
Internetrechte wahrscheinlich nicht für
ein paar Prozentpunkte an ein anderes
Unternehmen abgeben Casa und deswegen
mussten wir immer wieder abwägen ob wir
einsteigen oder nicht
ich glaube Netflix hatte großes Glück
das Blockbuster der schlafende Riese
nichts unternommen hat und sie schliefen
weiter denn Reed ist ein Gentleman ich
glaube wenn man Netflix einen anderen
Chef gegeben hätte der ein bisschen
frecher und Reister gewesen wäre hätte
man Blockbuster vielleicht dazu
provoziert zu konkurrieren
es gab keinen Grund mit Blockbuster zu
konkurrieren Ende 2000 war Netflix in
den roten Zahlen die Verluste stiegen
auf 57 Millionen Dollar es hörte sich
einfach an wie eine weitere.com Idee wie
eToys und die meisten Investoren waren
einfach davon überzeugt dass Netflix
eine kleine Nischen Idee war die Leute
wollten kein Abo es würde sich nie
durchsetzen
während Netflix darum kämpft der
profitabel zu werden Tat Reed Hastings
wieder etwas Unerwartetes er nahm einen
zusätzlichen Job in der staatlichen
Bildungsbehörde von Kalifornien an jeder
von ihnen hat schon mal versucht große
Organisationen zu verändern die erste
Hälfte der Schlacht besteht darin sie
auf den richtigen Kurs zu bringen er
wurde vom damaligen Gouverneur great
Davis ernannt wenn ich jemals in einem
Schützen Graben wäre hätte ich gerne
Reed Hastings bei mir denn wir würden
über die nächste Schulausschusssitzung
diskutieren und darüber wie die
Entscheidung ausfallen sollte
bald eine Entscheidung gefallen war ging
er da rein und blieb standhaft und
setzte die Reform durch
Netflix dagegen war alles andere als
etabliert und ging in den Dotcom
Sturzflug über wie sind die Helden
gefallen und einer aktuellen Studie von
morgen Stanley Dean Wetter hat die
durchschnittliche internetaktie zwei
Drittel von ihrem 52 Wochen hoch
eingebüßt
natürlich hatte schon lange einen
Börsengang geplant als der Markt in eine
Abwärtsspirale geriet Sparrow gun
beim ersten Versuch eines Börsengangs
sahen wir uns mit vielen Hindernissen
konfrontiert die Blase war geplatzt man
glaubte das Internetunternehmen keine
Substanz hätten es gab die antragsangst
es gab den 11 September
es war ein Desaster bei dem alles in die
falsche Richtung lief
Hastings sagte den Börsengang ab
und musste im Oktober 2001 jeden dritten
Mitarbeiter entlassen Netflix stand am
Rande der Katastrophe i think will ich
glaube Netflix hätte zwischen 99 und
2002 jederzeit untergehen können wenn es
ernsthafte Konkurrenz gegeben hätte
als das Jahr zu Ende ging kam der
Durchbruch
die Preise für DVD-Player fielen und
Hastings legte fast jeder neuen Box
einen Gutschein für eine kostenlose
Testversion von Netflix bei das Geschäft
lief gut
nachdem das Unternehmen wieder auf Kurs
war wurde der Börsengang 2002
Wirklichkeit in 2000
die netflix-aktie stieg am ersten Tag
rund 12 Prozent auf 16 Dollar 75 aber es
war ein zweischneidiges Schwert Keith
Terry beobachtet Netflix als
internetexperte bei Kenneth core genuady
der Börsengang verschaffte Netflix viel
Aufmerksamkeit nicht nur bei den
Verbrauchern sondern auch bei den
Konkurrenten und so wurde die Konkurrenz
von Unternehmen wie Walmart und
etablierten Anbietern wie Blockbuster
immer größer
Walmart startete seinen konkurrierenden
Dienst im Jahr 2003 ein Jahr später
stieg auch Blockbuster ein wir sind
anfangs ähnlich wie Netflix gestartet
nämlich mit einer kostenlosen
Testmitgliedschaft eines der schönsten
Worte in der amerikanischen Sprache ist
kostenlos und das brachte uns ein
ordentliches Wachstum
Blockbuster nahm außerdem 2 Euro weniger
an Monatsgebühren was einem hässlichen
Preiskrieg auslöste Netflix senkte den
Preis
Blockbuster konterte
Walmart unterbot beide also ging
Blockbuster noch weiter runter bei einer
Telefonkonferenz am Ende des Jahres
erklärte Hastings Blockbuster hat uns
mit allem beworfen außer mit der
Küchenspüle
ich und einige wichtige Mitglieder des
Management-Teams saßen in meinem Büro
und hörtende Telefonkonferenz zu jemand
sagte warum schicken wir ihm nicht seine
Spüle gute Idee am nächsten Tag haben
wir eine verschickt damit war die
Feindschaft natürlich im Beton gegossen
der harte Wettbewerb forderte seinen
Tribut Ticket die netflix-aktie stürzte
um 75% ab der Analyst Michael Patcher
kommentierte Netflix sei ein wertloses
Stück Scheiße das von wirklich netten
Leuten geleitet wird
ich war überzeugt dass Blockbuster
effektiv Konkurrenz machen würde und ich
dachte wenn Blockbuster entschlossen war
seine Kunden zu behalten dann würde
Netflix verschwinden
Hastings ging nicht kampflos unter er
opferte Gewinne um die Konkurrenz
zurückzudrängen und das Wachstum
aufrecht zu erhalten
es wurde ein Zermürbungskrieg
sie waren der Meinung dass Netflix nicht
in der Lage sein würde so einen
Wettbewerb zu überleben und das
Blockbuster und dann Walmart
letztendlich nur noch die Gewinne aus
Netflix herauspressen würden und ich
glaube was beide Unternehmen in ziemlich
kurzer Zeit herausfinden war dieses
Geschäft war viel schwieriger als sie
dachten
während der Kampf mit Blockbuster und
Walmart tobte erlitt Hastings einen
persönlichen Rückschlag vier Jahre lang
hatte er sich im kalifornischen
Bildungsministerium für eine Schulreform
engagiert doch als er mehr zweisprachige
Programme forderte warfen ihm die
demokratischen Abgeordneten raus
es war Tag für ihn es kam überraschend
und es war sicher auch demütigend von
seiner eigenen politischen Partei
abgelehnt zu werden
aber er sagte wenn das euer Grund ist
mich aus dem Schulausschuss zu werfen
dann gehe ich stolz und erhobenen
Hauptes
Hastings konzentrierte sich auf den
Kampf seines Unternehmens um das
dvd-versandgeschäft und Mitte 2005
begann sich das Blatt zu wenden
Walmart zog sich zurück und überließ
Netflix seine like-kunden im Tausch
gegen Verkaufsförderung
Blockbuster gewann zwar Abonnenten
verlor aber Hunderte von Millionen
Dollar nun war Hastings an der Reihe
jemanden als nett zu bezeichnen wir sind
nicht gegen Blockbuster das sind alles
nette Leute aber wir wollen einen
besseren Service anbieten damit die
Kunden uns vorziehen und das führt
gegebenenfalls dazu dass sie dicht
machen 2007 sagte antioco auf dem
Sundance Filmfestival in Utah dass er zu
einem Treffen mit Hastings eingeladen
wurde um über einen Deal zu sprechen
gehabt dass Netflix Blockbuster online
kauft aber wir haben ihm eine Fusion
vorgeschlagen es blieb beim Gesprächen
weil es Bedenken wegen der
kartellvorschriften gab
2008 war entirco weg und Blockbuster zog
sich aus dem Online-Geschäft zurück sie
haben Hunderte von Millionen Dollar
verloren als sie versuchten mit Netflix
zu konkurrieren und dafür hatten sie
einfach nicht das Geld man wusste dass
sie irgendwann aufgeben mussten und
genau das ist dann ja schließlich
passiert
es war ein Triumph für Netflix
pastings hatte sich das Geschäft mit den
Filmen per Post gesichert
2007 lieferte das Unternehmen die
milliardste DVD aus
dabei Hastings schon dabei Netflix mit
einem Dienst neu zu erfinden der
versprach die DVD überflüssig zu machen
Videos Streaming im Internet das war es
was er von Anfang an bei Netflix
vorausgesehen hatte es dauerte nur ein
Jahrzehnt bis es auch so ein traf wenn
es etwas gibt worauf man sich verlassen
kann dann dass die Technologie die
Bandbreite immer schneller und billiger
macht die Bandbreite mag billiger
gewesen sein aber nicht die Chance im
Gegensatz zu DVDs brauchte Netflix für
jeden gestreamten Film eine Lizenz und
die Gebühren waren astronomisch Andrew
wollansteen vom hollywood-magazin bereit
ich glaube die Titel mit denen Netflix
anfing waren wahrscheinlich der unterste
Bodensatz das waren die Filme oder
Fernsehsendungen die schon lange
vergessen waren nicht die besten Sachen
ich erinnere mich an eine spöttische
Bemerkung und eine Notiz darüber dass
niemand Operation Kleinhirn drei sehen
wollte als der Film Anfang der 90er
Jahre rauskam
wollten sie in 2007 sicher auch nicht
sehen
selbst wenn sie es wollten Netflix
konnte nur auf ein Gerät streamen
nämlich den PC
wir sehen uns keine Filme auf unserem PC
an wer streamt auf den PC wen
interessiert sowas das war verrückt wir
dachten wirklich es sei verrückt also
bot Hastings diesen Service den
Abonnenten kostenfrei an als er dann
ankündigte wir werden das kostenlos
anbieten da waren wir uns sicher dass er
verrückt ist
[Musik]
er bemühte sich auch um mehr Inhalte
fügte in weniger als zwei Jahren 11.000
Titel hinzu und sicherte sich einen
bahnbrechenden Vertrag für erst
aufgeführte Filme und Serien
zu dem Deal den sie mit Stars
abgeschlossen haben dadurch bekam sie
großartige Filme aus der sony-bibliothek
der disneybibliothek und sie bekam den
Deal für nur etwa 20 Millionen Dollar
das war das Schnäppchen des Jahrzehnts
es folgten Deals mit vielen der großen
Studios
es ist mir eine Freude Ihnen den Netflix
CEO retastings vorzustellen noch
beeindruckender war wie schnell Netflix
das Streaming auf nerd-geräte ausweitete
Erfolg für uns und für fast jedes
Unterhaltungssystem auf dem Planeten das
Wachstum hielt an
2011 erreichte die Zahl der Abonnenten
die 20 Millionen Marke ein Umsatz von
über 2 Milliarden Dollar weckte die
Aufmerksamkeit der Branchen Goliaths
Amazon Apple Google und Facebook das
sind alles 800 Pfund Gorillas das konnte
gefährlich werden für Netflix wenn ich
überlege ob es eine Zeit gab in der sie
mehr Druck ausgesetzt waren mir fällt
keiner ein
überraschenderweise kam der wirkliche
Druck nicht von diesen Tech Giganten
sondern von einer Reihe eigener
Fehlentscheidungen
im Juli 2011 kündigte Netflix an seine
Abo-Gebühr um 60% zu erhöhen
800.000 Kunden liefen davon zwei Monate
später entschuldigte sich Hastings
reumütig wir machen dieses Video heute
um uns persönlich zu entschuldigen er
kündigte an das Netflix sein DVD und
Streaming Geschäft aufteilen würde die
Preiserhöhung blieb aber aus dividi bei
Mail sollte eine neue Marke werden
quickster der Plan scheiterte Kunden und
Aktionäre flüchteten weiter wollten Abos
und Aktien loswerden Netflix nun in
einer Abwärtsspirale war gezwungen einen
Rückzieher zu machen Netflix drückt
heute den rückspul-knopf das Unternehmen
macht eine große Kehrtwende und sagt
quickster ist tot und die DVD und
Streaming-Dienste wieder unter einem
Dach der Grund dafür ist einfach die
Kunden mochten es einfach nicht Hastings
entschuldigte sich erneut
diesmal dafür dass er zu schnell
gehandelt hat
quickster wurde zum Symbol dafür dass
Netflix nicht gehört hat und wir haben
den Kurs schnell geändert wir halten an
DVDs als Teil der netflix-marke fest es
war ein epischer Einbruch Netflix verlor
innerhalb von drei Monaten fast zwei
Drittel seines Wertes an einem Tag
atemberaubende 2,3 Milliarden und als ob
das nicht schon genug wäre trennten sich
Netflix und Stars was Netflix die
neueren Filme von Disney und Sony
vorenthielt und den Eindruck hinterließ
Netflix verliere Inhalte und erhöhe
trotzdem die Preise hast
kündigte neue Vereinbarungen mit
DreamWorks Animation relativity AMC sea
Double You und anderen an
er habe nie daran gedacht zurückzutreten
sagt er
wolle am Erfolg von 12 Jahren gemessen
werden und nicht an den Fehlern von
zwölf
wochenweise wie wir alle über den Konsum
von Unterhaltung Denken verändert er hat
die Möglichkeiten wie man Filme kommt
erweitert
ich würde Reed Hastings und Netflix
nicht abschreiben sie kennen Ihre
Herausforderungen und verstecken sich
nicht davor es gibt nur sehr wenige
Unternehmen die so viele Dinge getan
haben und damit Erfolg hatten
und wissen sie zwölf Jahre später ist es
wieder eines dieser Unternehmen dass man
vielleicht nicht mag über dessen Erfolge
man aber nicht streiten kann
[Musik]
Richard Branson der Mann mit dem
goldenen Händchen und dem
milliardärslächeln
er ist sagenhaft reich berühmt wie ein
Rockstar und scheint sich immer gut zu
amüsieren
ich habe riesiges Glück gehabt ich habe
jede Minute meines Lebens genossen ich
würde mit niemanden tauschen wollen
Reichtum beeindruckt ihn nicht ihm geht
es eher um die Frage habe ich Spaß man
braucht ein Gleichgewicht Branson hat
einen sexy Namen Virgin in markengold
verwandelt mit über 300 Waren und
Dienstleistungen von Rock über
Flugreisen bis hin zu Handys und Zügen
wir haben es mit den fetten Unternehmen
aufgenommen nicht wirklich viel über den
Verbraucher nachgedacht haben und wir
sind hin und haben sie aufgerüttelt wenn
man die Risiken analysieren würde die er
eingegangen ist würde man nicht
mitmachen denn keine Risikoanalyse würde
sagen mach weiter so um alles über
Wasser zu halten wurde Branson zu seinem
eigenen besten Berber indem er Abenteuer
und Spaß auslebte und dafür sein eigenes
Leben aufs Spiel setzte ich habe
vermutlich fast die Gelegenheit
ausgelassen um zu versuchen mich
umzubringen und ich habe das große Glück
heute hier zu sein um über diese
Geschichten zu sprechen wenn es so einen
Titel gäbe wäre Richard Branson
vielleicht wirklich der interessanteste
Mann der Welt
besitzt seine eigene Insel fliegt mit
Balance um den Globus arbeitet mit den
großen der Welt zusammen und plant ein
Virgin U-Boot zum unerforschten
Meeresgrund zu bringen
man lebt nur einmal und wir akzeptieren
dass es mit Risiken verbunden ist etwas
zu tun was die Menschheit noch nicht
getan hat aber wir tun es mit offenen
Augen
Branson verbrachte einen Großteil seines
Lebens auf dem Hochseil des
unternehmerischen Risikos Herr häufte
ein Vermögen von mehr als 4 Milliarden
Dollar an nicht böse sein
ich war nie daran interessiert Geld zu
verdienen ich meine viele Leute werden
sagen das ist leicht zu sagen wenn man
viel Geld gemacht hat aber ich war
einfach daran interessiert Dinge zu
schaffen Dinge auf die ich stolz sein
kann und eine Menge Spaß dabei zu haben
Richard Charles Nicolas Branson wurde am
18 Juli 1950 am Stadtrand von London
geboren
sein Vater war Rechtsanwalt seine Mutter
eine ehemalige Flugbegleiterin als
schwerer Legastheniker konnte er im
Alter von acht Jahren kaum lesen und war
mit Zahlen hoffnungslos überfordert
die Schule war schmerzhaft die schaute
auf eine Tafel und verstand nichts
interessanterweise wenn man sich die
Geschichten von Legasthenikern anguckt
schneiden sie oft ganz besonders gut ab
weil sie sich auf die Bereiche
konzentrieren in denen sie gut sind
sie lernen sicher sehr früh Sachen zu
delegieren
Nick paul war der engste Freund und
später Geschäftspartner von Branson
ich habe bei Richard immer gedacht er
wird die Welt verändern
man konnte schon früh erkennen dass er
Qualitäten hatte die unter all den
anderen Freunden die wir hatten nicht
üblich waren wir machten immer Mutproben
saßen auf beiden Seiten der weißen Linie
und es ging darum wer sich als Letzter
bewegt wenn das Auto die Straße
runterkommt Richard gewann immer
aber Branson hatte eine starke
unternehmerische Ader mit 13 versuchte
er Weihnachtsbäume zu verkaufen
er versuchte Sittiche zu züchten
mit 15 beschloss er eine nationale
Studentenzeitung zu gründen ich
arbeitete von einer Telefonzelle an der
Schule aus rief Coca-Cola an rief Leute
an ob sie für die Zeitschrift schreiben
wollen rief die barclys Bank an ob Sie
eine Anzeige schalten und diese
Schlangen von Leuten vor der
Telefonzelle als ich noch mehr Geld
einwarf
die Zeitschrift Student war ein
sofortiger Erfolg mit einer Auflage von
50.000 Stück
Graham boyton war reisereporter für den
London Telegraph und berichtete über 20
Jahre lang über Branson
obwohl er ein Kind der 60er Jahre war
war immer etwas unbeholfen ich glaube
was passierte war das das Unternehmen
ihm einen Wortschatz seine tiefe gab und
von Dahn ging es weiter
1970 gründete Branson einen
Versandhandel für discountplatten mit
dem erhoffte Geld für die Zeitschrift zu
bekommen die erste Aufgabe bestand darin
einen Namen zu finden
alte Vinylplatten die immer wieder
verrutschten und jemand anderes lachte
weißt du warum nicht Virgin wir sind
doch alle Jungfrauen ich dachte
plötzlich ich bin Jungfrau im Geschäft
weißt du ich könnte auch in anderen
Dingen eine jungen Frau sein also warum
nicht Virgin
ein poststreik brachte den
plattenversand 1971 fast zum Erliegen
Branson beschloss einen Platten Laden zu
eröffnen einen mit Kopfhörern und
Wasserkissen der sich an jüngere Leute
richtete simon dreper
war sein erster plattenkäufer und der
spätere Leiter von Virgin Records alle
wurden gleich bezahlt so dass man das
Gefühl hatte niemand darf mehr Geld
verdienen als die anderen aber wenn man
mal darüber nachdenkt war es eigentlich
ganz praktisch denn so konnte man allen
weniger zahlen
einige der Leute die für Richard in den
Plattenläden in Notting Hill gearbeitet
haben haben Platten gestohlen und sie
waren total erstaunt als Richard sie
wegen Diebstahls gefeuert hat er war vom
ersten Tag an darauf getrimmt ein
Geschäftsmann zu sein
fünf Monate nach der Eröffnung des
Ladens wurde Branson plötzlich wegen
Steuerhinterziehung verhaftet
er hatte seine Platten zum Teil billiger
angeboten weil er einen Weg gefunden
hatte die schallplattensteuer zu umgehen
er verbrachte eine Nacht im Gefängnis
und seine Eltern mussten ihr Haus
beleihen um ihn rauszuholen
wieso
mitmischen zu können müsste er Steuern
umgehen das muss ein großer Schock für
ihn gewesen sein er war extrem verärgert
aber er hat sich tadellos Verhalten
niemand sonst bekam irgendwelche Strafen
ich hatte es geschafft einen
strafrechtliches Verfahren zu vermeiden
indem ich bezahlte was verlangt wurde
und wir haben unsere Plattenläden sehr
schnell erweitert so dass wir den Umsatz
hatten um die Schulden abzubezahlen
seitdem habe ich dafür gesorgt dass
alles sauber ablief damit wir uns keine
Sorgen machen mussten dass jemand an die
Tür klopft
um 150.000 Dollar Bußgeld zu begleichen
und einen Gerichtsprozess oder sogar
eine Haftstrafe zu umgehen gründete
Branson ein Aufnahmestudio und ein neues
Plattenlabel
zusammen mit seinem Cousin Simon dreper
ihr erster Vertragspartner war ein
Unbekannter folklorist Mike Oldfield mit
einem seltsamen Instrumentalalbum namens
Tubular Bells
wir haben uns gefragt ob wir wetten
sollten wie oft sich dieses Album wohl
verkaufen würde ich dachte vielleicht
20.000 mal was mir zu der Zeit viel
erschien aber Millionen später sie
wissen schon eine ganz andere Geschichte
16 Millionen um genau zu sein über Nacht
machte die Platte Virgin bekannt
und Richard Branson noch nicht ganz 23
zum Millionär Branson steckte all seine
Gewinne in neue Künstler und Unternehmen
aber das verunsicherte seine
Partners Nick Paul leistete so viel
Widerstand dass Branson ihn auszahlte
ich glaube nicht dass wir genug Cashflow
hatten um das Geschäft weiter so
expandieren zu können und ich lag falsch
ich bin vielleicht bereit mehr
einzusetzen als ich anderen Leuten raten
würde es gibt Fälle wo ich meine Frau
dazu gebracht habe ein Papier zu
unterschreiben und sie hat nicht gemerkt
dass das Haus für dieses Geschäft aufs
Spiel gesetzt wird
1984 lebte Richard Branson im Leben
eines Rock'n'Roll Königs ihm gehörte
diese Insel auf den britischen
jungferninsel
und Virgin Records war eines der
erfolgreichsten unabhängigen Labels der
Welt
the Sex Pistols Simple Minds
Human League Culture Club waren
Verkaufsschlager
Branson war reich und wollte das Geld
ausgeben aus heiterem Himmel rief ein
versicherungsanwalt namens Randolf
fields an und bat Branson um Hilfe bei
einer transatlantischen Fluggesellschaft
wisst ihr was ich hasse es mit den
Airlines anderer Leute zu reisen und wir
können das besser machen
meine Anteile die ich damals besaß 15
Prozent der gesamten Virgin Group wurden
ziemlich wertvoll also war ich entsetzt
und sagte das ist der Anfang vom Ende
unserer Beziehung
Branson startete seine Fluggesellschaft
mit einer gebrauchten 747 die er von
Boeing leste
[Musik]
Unternehmen noch ich sagte nun Virgin
wir sind die Leute die in die sexpistols
und die Rolling Stones gebracht haben
schmerzhaft nun bei einem solchen Namen
hoffen wir mal dass das was wird wir
werden es versuchen
nachdem er fields herausgekauft hatte
beschloss Branson eine bessere Mischung
aus economy und Business class-tarifen
anzubieten wobei der Schwerpunkt auf
nonstop Spaß lag
[Musik]
der eröffnungsflug von London nach New
York New York gab den Ton an
ich kann Ihnen sagen das war eine Orgie
es war wild es wurde getrunken waren
oben ohne Models im Flugzeug es war
einfach eine Party und Richard gab den
Turner
David Tate die erste Person die Branson
einstellte war eine Führungskraft bei
Virgin Atlantic
die Tür des Flugzeugs öffnete war dass
wir ein Champagnerkorken der aus der
Flasche kommt ich glaube es wurde nie so
viel Champagner getrunken wie auf diesem
Flug
mit nur einem Flugzeug und einer Strecke
war Bransons erstes Problem die Werbung
er hatte nicht das Werbebudget um mit
British Airways und den anderen riesigen
Fluggesellschaften zu konkurrieren also
nahm er die Sache selbst in die Hand und
begann eine Reihe atemberaubender
ballon- und boot-trips die Virgin
Airlines schnell bekannt machen sollte
dies ist der Beginn eines großen
Abenteuers sein Flug über den Atlantik
1987 faszinierte die medienwochenlang
fünf Menschen waren bei früheren
Versuchen ums Leben gekommen
in meine Hände und ich musste auf ihn
aufpassen
als sie die Irische See erreichten
schleuderten heftige Winde den Ballon
gegen die Wellen nein deine blühne ist
ein Partner der mehr Erfahrung mit
Ballonfahren hatte sprang aus dem Ballon
ich blieb allein zurück und der Ballon
stieg auf 10 15.000 Fuß
ich war im Wasser rich im Ballon und er
wusste nicht wirklich wie das
funktioniert ich hatte noch nie so viel
Angst in meinem Leben
Branson schaffte es den Ballon
herunterzuholen und sprang ins eiskalte
Wasser
ein Hubschrauber der Luftstreitkräfte
holte ihn zusammen mit per heraus der
nach zwei Stunden schwimmen fast
gestorben war
Richard ist eine Mischung aus der Turner
er würde ja sagen ich fahre mit dem
Ballon weil es gute Werbung für die
Firma ist
aber er tut das weil es ihm Spaß macht
wenn er eine Katze wäre ja schon beim
dritten Set von neuen Leben Ende 1989
vergrößerte sich Richard Bransons Welt
an allen Fronten er heiratete seine
langjährige Partnerin Joanne tempelman
auf Neckar Island das Paar hatte schon
zwei Kinder in vierjährigen Sam und die
achtjährige Holly auch das Unternehmen
expandierte Branson hatte die Virgin
Group 1986 an die Börse gebracht was
mehr als 56 Millionen Dollar einbrachte
ich glaube nicht dass ein Börsengang die
Art wie wir unsere geschäftlich führen
sehr verändern wird das erwies sich als
falsch es machte sehr wohl einen
Unterschied Branson
heute es einem Aufsichtsrat Rechenschaft
abzulegen und kaufte Virgin zurück nun
lenkte er ein kleines aber prekäres
Imperium mit einer Airline die ständig
Gefahr lief unterzugehen
und schlimmer noch British Airways war
entschlossen seinen aufstrebenden
Rivalen zu vernichten
die Rivalität zwischen British Airways
und Virgin Atlantic war mir immer ein
Rätsel
ich glaube es Lagern britischen
Establishment sie sahen diesen jungen
rücksichtslosen memorcamling mit langen
Haaren das hat sie einfach echt
verärgert
so sehr dass British Airways 1991 etwas
startete dass die Presse als Kampagne
der schmutzigen Tricks bezeichnete
verschlossenen Türen die sich illegal
Zugang zu unseren Computerdaten
verschafften unsere Passagiere anriefen
Vorgaben von Virgin Atlantic zu sein wir
hätten Flüge gestrichen und wuchten sie
auf brit sie hatten Leute die meine
Mülleimer durchsuchten die Mülleimer
unserer Clubs durchsuchten um
irgendeinen Schmutz über uns zu finden
sie platzierten stories in der Presse
und so weiter
und das schlimmste Branson war überzeugt
dass British Airways Gerüchte schürte
Virgin sei insolvent und stehe kurz vor
dem Untergang
von Virgin Galactic und arbeitet seit
1987 eng mit Branson zusammen jeden Tag
an dem du mit leeren sitzen abhebst
verlierst du Geld wenn also jemand
Passagiere davon überzeugt nicht bei
einer bestimmten Airline zu buchen weil
sie glauben dass sie pleite geht dann
wird sie pleite gehen Branson kämpfte
darum Virgin Atlantic am Leben zu
erhalten und wieder einmal setzte er
dafür sein Leben aufs Spiel er startete
zu einer weiteren gefährlichen
Ballonfahrt dieses Mal über den Pazifik
mitten über den Pazifik verloren wir
zwei volle klebstofftanks und wir
wussten nicht ob wir noch genug haben um
es zu schaffen
wir mussten diesen Ballon mit einer
Durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit von über
180 Meilen pro Stunde fliegen und wir
wurden ja nur vom Wind angetrieben also
waren die Chancen total gering aber dann
kamen wir genau in dem Kern des
Jetstreams und sahen plötzlich wieder
Geschwindigkeitsmesser stieg 160 170 180
190/210 220 ich bin kein religiöser
Mensch aber es war als ob jemand da oben
diesen Ballon genommen und angeschoben
hätte mitten durch den Jetstream
Branson und Lynn strange stürzten über
einem zugefrorenen See ab 300 Meilen vom
nächsten Wohnort entfernt wir verfehlten
unser Ziel um dreieinhalbtausend Meilen
und landeten in der Arktis in einem
Schneesturm bei minus 60 Grad aber wir
hätten nicht glücklicher sein können in
dem Moment als Branson Ausstieg war er
tatsächlich schon ein Superstar
auch sein Plattenlabel lief heiß Virgin
Records nahm janet Jackson und die
Rolling Stones unter Vertrag
aber die Schmutzkampagne von British
Airways gegen Virgin Atlantic machte es
unmöglich Kredite zu bekommen um die
Airline zu retten musste Branson die
härteste Entscheidung seines Lebens
treffen er beschloss seine Geliebte
Plattenfirma zu verkaufen Penny Pike war
31 Jahre lang seine persönliche
Assistentin jeder war furchtbar
geschockt ich meine Richard war noch
geschockter als alle anderen und er
weinte und weinte und weinte es war als
würde man ein Kind verkaufen ich sagte
es dem Personal Drachen Tränen aus
rannte zurück zu meinem Haus und kam an
diesem Schild vorbei auf dem Stand
Branson verkauft für eine Milliarde
Dollar und mir wurde klar dass das Leben
gar nicht so schlecht war er hat die
Zukunft von Virgin Atlantic gesichert
weil er danach genug Kapital hatte um
jedem Konkurrenten ins Gesicht schauen
und sagen zu können weißt du was ich
kann das genauso lange aussetzen wie du
die Leute sagten damals wir seien
verrückte Plattenfirma zu verkaufen um
das Geld in eine Airline zu stecken aber
später ist die Plattenindustrie ja
zusammengebrochen und die Flugindustrie
hat sich nicht so schlecht für uns
entwickelt einen Monat nach dem
milliardenschweren Deal verklagte
Branson British Airways wegen
Verleumdung die Fluggesellschaft einigte
sich außergerichtlich und zahlte 1,1
Millionen Dollar
wir haben den höchsten Schadenersatz
aller verleumdungsfälle gewonnen und sie
mussten sich öffentlich entschuldigen
[Musik]
oh Richard Branson war überglücklich
dieser Tag war wahrscheinlich einer der
großartigsten seiner Karriere er hatte
es geschafft er hat die mächtige British
Airways vertreten da night die besondere
von diesem Abend telefonierte er mit
verschiedenen Leuten und er hatte diese
Entschlossenheit in seiner Stimme das
war der Moment er wollte Virgin Atlantic
zu einem weltweiten Erfolg machen er
wollte es nehmen und es auf der ganzen
Welt ausbauen
nachdem er 1992 Virgin Records für eine
Milliarde Dollar verkauft hatte war
Richard Branson bereit sein wertvollstes
Gut zu verwerten die Marke werden
es wurde plötzlich klar dass wir etwas
haben dass wir schützen und pflegen
müssen die Marke ist letztlich das worum
es bei Virgin geht
Branson war die Marke und er hat sie
unermüdlich gefördert
bis heute hat er über 300 Produkte und
Dienstleistungen virginisiert ich glaube
wenn man etwas schafft auf das man stolz
sein kann dann wird es wahrscheinlich
erfolgreich sein aber sind denke ich
dachte nicht los wir bringen diese Marke
jetzt in alle möglichen Bereiche ich
dachte man könnte es mit Fitnessstudios
probieren oder mit dem Mobilfunkgeschäft
einige Versuche wie Virgin Brights und
Virgin Cola verpufften schnell wieso
trains startete stockend die
Infrastruktur war marode und es dauerte
Jahre bis die Züge pünktlich fuhren aber
andere Vorstöße hatten atemberaubenden
Erfolg
1999 stieß Branson auf eine Goldader er
schloss sich mit Dienstleistern zusammen
um Virgin mobile zu gründen sie
lieferten das Netz er das Marketing und
den Namen
sowie die innovative Idee die Kunden
während der Fahrt bezahlen zu lassen
Bert Schmitz Professor an der School of
Business der Columbia University ist
Experte für Markenbildung der Wert einer
Marke liegt wirklich in den
immateriellen Werten Kunden kaufen nicht
nur Produkte sie kaufen nicht nur
Funktionalität sie kaufen auch ein Image
sie kaufen einen Lebensstil sie kaufen
eine Erfahrung er steht für bestimmte
Dinge er steht für Service für
Kundenerlebnis für Innovationen für Spaß
Branson war jetzt der businesskönig
1999 wurde er vom Königshaus seines
Landes geehrt die Königin schlug ihn zum
Ritter als Ikone des Millenniums für
seinen Beitrag zum Handel
[Musik]
fünf Jahre später brachte er Virgin
mobile an die Börse nach eigenen Angaben
wurde das Unternehmen mit 1,5 Milliarden
Dollar bewertet
[Musik]
jedes Unternehmen der Virgin Group
bleibt unabhängig
so dass kein Misserfolg das Imperium zu
Fall bringen kann trotzdem stellen
Analysten regelmäßig den Wert der Virgin
Group in Frage die sich immer noch in
privater Hand befindet der Headline die
Schlagzeilen lauteten wann wird Bransons
Ballon platzen und jedes Mal wenn wir
etwas Neues starteten erstrapaziert die
Marke zu sehr und manchmal lagen sie
weiter neben die Virgin Group gründete
immer wieder neue Unternehmen
2004 kündigte Branson eines seiner
fantasievollsten an
er will Menschen ins Weltall bringen
angefangen bei seiner eigenen Mutter ich
glaube wir stehen 18 Monate vor dem
Start ins All und damit vor dem Beginn
eines völlig neuen Bereichs der
kommerziellen Raumfahrt hoffentlich
werden hunderte wenn ich tausende von
Menschen die Möglichkeit haben
Astronauten zu werden und ins All zu
fliegen
es ist eine enormes Risiko es ist als
würde man seinen Namen seine Marke auf
ein Formel-1-Rennwagen setzen es ist
toll wenn er gewinnt aber wenn er sich
irgendwo meinen Betonmast wickelt hat
das eine Menge Nachteile diente die
Marke Virgin 2006 noch weiter aus da
seine Airline Tonnen von CO2 in die
Atmosphäre spuckt verpflichtete er sich
alle Gewinne seiner Transportunternehmen
in den nächsten zehn Jahren ungefähr
drei Milliarden Dollar in die Forschung
für einen umweltfreundlichen
Biokraftstoff zu investieren
und er rief den ältesten Rat ins Leben
ein Krisenintervention stream-team unter
der Leitung von Nelson Mandela
ich war 55 Jahre alt heute gutes Geld
verdient und konnte so gut wie jeden
anrufen und Dinge durchsetzen plötzlich
war ich in einer Situation in der ich
vielleicht etwas in der Welt bewirken
konnte
Kritiker machten sich über den neuen
sozialen Branson lustig und verwiesen
auf die offshore-steuer-oase die er seit
Jahren nutzt um sein Vermögen zu
schützen ich glaube nicht dass Richard
sich von den anderen sehr reichen
Geschäftsleuten unterscheidet er hat her
Schaden von Buchhaltern und Anwälten die
ihm sagen wir wissen wo sie ihr Geld
verstecken können
ist er der Unternehmer des Volkes
nur bis zu einem gewissen Punkt war
nicht in der Lage sein gesamtes Vermögen
zu schützen virgin America hatte einen
schweren Staat und verlor fast 400
Millionen Dollar bevor es im dritten
Quartal 2010 begann Gewinn zu machen
mit Anfang 60 hat der Virgin König eine
lange und aufregende Reise hinter sich
Branson hat sich sein Glück selbst
erarbeitet er war sehr sehr gut darin es
ist nicht nur ein goldenes Händchen er
hat dafür gearbeitet natürlich treibt
ihn das Geld an aber Reichtum
beeindruckt ihn nicht sondern eher die
Frage habe ich Spaß habe ich Aufregung
man braucht ein Gleichgewicht
bin extrem ich hatte außerordentliches
Glück ich habe jede Minute meines Lebens
gelassen in Zukunft werde ich die meiste
Zeit damit verbringen gemeinnützige
Unternehmen zu gründen und sie dabei zu
beobachten wie sie einige der großen
Probleme der Welt angehen aber
gleichzeitig werden wir immer noch
wunderbare Abenteuer erleben wir werden
in den Weltraum fliegen auf den Grund
der Ozeane gehen und uns immer noch
anstrengend meine Kinder und die
Menschen um mich herum herausfordern und
eine Menge Spaß haben
er ist der Samurai Krieger des Silicon
Valley Larrys Einstellung ist wenn du
gegen mich antreten willst dann sei
bereits zerquetscht zu werden
Larry Allison startete Oracle Software
vor über 30 Jahren und das machte ihn
zum bestbezahlten Manager der letzten
zehn Jahre mit einer Vergütung von 1,84
Milliarden Dollar
niemand konnte wie Larry einen Kunden
glauben machen mit seinem Produkt dessen
Geschäftsleben verändern könnte
er sieht schon um die Ecke lange bevor
andere das Ende der Straße erreichen er
tut alles um zu gewinnen im Büro SAP die
deutsche Softwarefirma wurde verurteilt
Oracle 1,3 Milliarden Dollar zu zahlen
oder auf dem Meer das besteht kein
Zweifel dass er es Hass zu verlieren die
Technologie seines Unternehmens wurde
zum Rückgrat der weltweiten
Informationssysteme von der Regierung
bis zum Online-Handel der dreiste
Milliardär ist ein ehrgeiziger
Provokateur mit einem einzigartigen
Führungsstil
Larrys nachfolgeplant für Oracle lautet
wahrscheinlich
wie kann ich Oracle weiterführen wenn
ich einen Meter 80 unter der Erde
[Applaus]
okay
wenn sie irgendetwas über Larry Allison
wissen ist es wahrscheinlich ungefähr
das hier ich habe einen Bugatti
schnellste Auto der Welt dieses Haus
kostet 200 Millionen Dollar das
schnellste Segelboot das jemals gebaut
wurde ich bin süchtig danach zu gewinnen
er ist ein adrenalinjunkie einen und
einen kompromissloser Sammler von teurem
Spielzeug
2010 gab er 400 Millionen Dollar aus um
den America's Cup die älteste
Sporttrophäe zum ersten Mal seit 15
Jahren wieder nach Amerika zu holen
aber die Wurzeln seines Erfolges sind
sehr viel unauffälliger einige der
weltweit wichtigsten Software-Tools von
denen sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht
wissen dass seine Firma sie zum Laufen
bringt
[Musik]
fast jeder auf der Welt benutzt Oracle
sie wissen es manchmal bei allen
möglichen Transaktionen mit fast jeder
Regierung der Welt
jeder geschäftlichen Transaktion mit
fast jedem traditionellen oder
Internetunternehmen der Welt Stopp
Business wenn Sie eine Kreditkarte haben
wenn sie ein Handy haben werden sie
irgendeins der modernsten Dinge des
Lebens haben dann Verbänden sie
wahrscheinlich Oracle
Barry Allison hat wohl die wichtigste
Computersoftware entwickelt von der sie
je gehört haben er war der Mann hinter
der riesigen Veränderung unserer
Lebensweise auch Alison blieb im
Hintergrund als wir versuchten ihn für
die Teilnahme an diesem Programm zu
gewinnen
1944 in der Bronx geboren wuchs Alison
in Chicago auf als er 12 war
überrumpelte sein Vater ihn mit einer
Nachricht
mein Dad sagte kurz vor dem Abendessen
ach übrigens du bist adoptiert und heute
Abend essen wir Hackbraten es war so
schockierend ich habe so einfach
verdrängt und jahrelang darüber
nachgedacht ohne mich wirklich damit zu
konfrontieren
war ein mittelmäßiger Schüler mochte die
formale Bildung nicht Mike Wilson ist
Redakteur für die ST Petersburger times
und hat Alison für seine
biografie-interviewt Gary wollte keine
Regeln befolgen weder in der Schule noch
in der Familie oder sonstwo er musste
aus dem Schatten von Louis Allison
hervorkommen und seinem Vater beweisen
dass er etwas aus sich machen konnte
sein Gespür für die Überholspur
offenbarte sich früh Larry ging los und
kaufte sich ein türkisblauen Thunderbird
er weint stylischer Typ wollte die Leute
beeindrucken da stiegen dieses Frankfurt
nach Kalifornien
hatte viel Potenzial
seine Reise nach Kalifornien spielte
eine große Rolle dabei wer werden würde
Alison kam nach Berkley und verdiente
sich seinen Lebensunterhalt als
Programmierer 1973 arbeitete er beim
Computer Elektronikhersteller emdal dort
lernte erst Steuern Felgen kennen sie
sind seit über 35 Jahren befreundet an
meinem ersten Arbeitstag ging ich in
meine Kabine und auf der anderen Seite
des Flurs standen ein paar Typen die nie
zu arbeiten schienen sie redeten die
ganze Zeit nur und einer von ihnen
redete nur über sich selbst
Hans luca war wie dumm alle anderen
waren und wie er eigentlich alles leiten
sollte das war Larry Allison Alison war
ein talentierter aber ungeduldiger
Programmierer der nach etwas suchte dass
er selbst kontrollieren konnte zu sagen
er hätte die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne eines
steppenläufers wäre übertrieben sie war
eher die eines Blitzes
das änderte sich als er einen Job bei
der Firma empex
bekamex hatte mit einem Projekt zu
kämpfen das von der CIA finanziert wurde
die Information driven CIA the proje es
trug den Code-Namen Oracle die CIA
brauchte ein System zum Speichern und
Abrufen großer Mengen ausländischer
Geheimdienstinformationen die sich auf
sensible Operationen und Missionen
bezogen für Alison war es die Aufgabe
seines Lebens und säte den Samen für
seine Zukunft in den 70er Jahren wurden
Daten noch auf Magnetband gespeichert
für die CIA zu unbeständig
und für Allison zu langsam er verließ
empex und gründete mit seinem Freund dem
programmiergenie Bob meiner eigene Firma
[Musik]
waren ein perfektes seltsames paar im
Silicon Valley bob hatte das technische
Talent Larry dagegen hatte die Fähigkeit
zu verkaufen die Vision
die Fähigkeit zu einem Kunden zu gehen
und zu erklären so kann sich Ihr
Geschäft verändern mit diesem
handgeschriebenen Schild um 1200 Dollar
gründeten sie software development
levelitory oder SDL Alison rekrutierte
die beiden Freunde at all und Stuart
Felgen er sagte er würde eine Art Firma
gründen und ich dachte das ist die
dümmste Idee von der ich je gehört habe
denn Larry war nicht berühmt dafür Dinge
zu Ende zu bringen ich habe immer gesagt
er ist eine totale Niete aus dem wird
nie was und ich hatte halbrechts neues
Unternehmen brauchte ein Produkt und
nachdem er eine obskure IBM
Forschungsarbeit gelesen hatte glaubte
er es zu haben eine Methode zum
Sortieren von Informationen die allen
bisherigen überlegen war
eine relationale Datenbank
Harry Blum der 14 Jahre mit Alison
zusammen arbeitete war das ein komplexer
Name aber eine einfache Idee die
relationale Datenbank was ist das Kreuz
ist eine Sammlung von Daten und
Informationen die in ein Format gebracht
werden dass es sehr einfach macht diese
Informationen zu suchen und zu finden
nichts kompliziertes
IBM sah das Potenzial ihrer
Möglichkeiten nicht Allison Sean ich
sagte oh mein Gott wir können IBM auf
dem Markt schlagen weil IBM nicht an
seine eigene Idee glaubt Alison glaubte
und bat Bruce Gott mit dem Programmieren
zu beginnen für mich ist es einfach eine
coole Technologie und macht Spaß aber
für Larry er sah die Firma sah den Markt
wir waren uns nicht sicher ob Larry
Recht hatte aber wir brauchten die Jobs
stand unter großem Druck irgendwie Geld
reinzubekommen to get some money and
some how 1977 war Alison
Startup-Unternehmen dabei eine Datenbank
zu erstellen von der sie dachten dass
sie Hardware Unternehmen Daten abrufen
und verwalten revolutionieren würde
drei Zimmer und ein kleiner Lobbybereich
wir waren so viert und schrieben
Programme Larry war damit beschäftigt
Kunden zu finden und das war irgendwie
bizarr weil wir keine Software hatten
also alles was sie in Büchern lesen über
jemanden der einen Anführer ist er weiß
nicht aber er war hartnäckig er würde
nie aufgeben
Harrison fand neue Kunden und wurde zum
wichtigsten Botschafter des Unternehmens
niemand hat besser auf Geschäftsmann
gemacht als Larry er konnte Kunden davon
überzeugen dass er mit seinem Produkt
ihr Geschäftsleben verändern würde
doch für das weltweite
geheimdienstmanagement brauchten sie
immer noch eine intelligentere Lösung
Allison verkaufte seine Datenbank an die
CIA seinen ersten Kunden und nannte die
neue Software Oracle Version 2 es gab
keine Version 1 weil alle dachten naja
das kauft doch niemand also haben wir
mit Version 2 angefangen sie war
mindestens so fehlerhaft wie die Version
1 von irgendjemand umsonst ich nannte
sie das Kakerlaken Hotel der Datenbanken
die datenvielen rein kamen aber nicht
mehr raus
1982 nahm Alison den Namen Oracle auch
für sein Unternehmen erzielte auf seine
sehr eigene Weise auf Regierungsbehörden
und große Unternehmen ab ich erinnere
mich dass er mir sehr deutlich sagte wir
können nicht erfolgreich sein wenn wir
die Kunden nicht anlügen aus irgendeinem
Grund erzählte Larry der Bank of America
dass wir 15 Leute waren obwohl wir fünf
waren ich war mir nicht sicher warum die
Bank anders von einem denken sollte wenn
man 15 statt 5 ist aber Larry hatte
ihnen eine Zahl gegeben die nicht
stimmte
Alison hatte auch eine
vertriebspilosophie die auf eine
Japan-Reise in den frühen 70er Jahren
zurückgehen
ich habe dort mit einem Geschäftsführer
gesprochen und er sagte das Problem mit
Amerika ist dass wir einfach keinen Sinn
für Wettbewerb haben
in Japan glauben wir dass unsere
Konkurrenten unseren Kindern den Reis
aus dem Mund stehlen und wir glauben
dass weniger als 100% Marktanteil nicht
ausreichen sein g über Leichen Ansatz
wurde bekannt als der Oracle way der
Oracle way war bis Mitte der 80er
einfach mit allen Mitteln zu gewinnen
Larrys Einstellung ist wenn du gegen
mich antreten willst dann sei bereit
zerquetscht zu werden oder tritt nicht
gegen mich an
die Oracle-Datenbank grob in einer
seiner Anzeigen ab wie ein Düsenjäger
und 1986 ging Oracle an die Börse seit
39 prozentiger Anteil am war
beeindruckende 93 Millionen Dollar wert
der Börsengang war ein riesen Erfolg
wurde aber schon am nächsten Tag von
Microsofts Börsengang überschattet der
Bill Gate seinen Anteil von 350
Millionen einbrachte
1989 zog Alison mit Oracle auf diesen
Campus in Redwood Shorts Kalifornien der
als smarten statt bekämpft wurde eine
Anspielung auf den Zauberer von Ost oder
wie eine Zeitung schrieb Larry lernt und
jeder wusste wer der Zauberer war
als ich einen Ferrari 348 bestellte und
den ersten davon in Kalifornien haben
wollte bestellte Larry einen irgendwo an
der Ostküste und ließ ihn verschicken
bevor ich meinen bekam er wollte nicht
der zweite sein er wollte der erste sein
seine Besessenheit der Erste zu sein
forderte ihren Tribut Oracle schlug
gegen eine Wand die sah aggressiven
Verkaufspraktiken fingen an echte
Probleme zu machen diese aggressiven
Verkaufspraktiken in den 80er Jahren
machten das Unternehmen zum Albtraum der
Buchhalter
die Vertriebsmitarbeiter waren so
aggressiv und heißt darauf Deals
abzuschließen und gleichzeitig gab es so
wenig geschäftliche Kontrolle
irgendwann bekamen wir das Problem dass
wir schlechte Verträge unterschrieben
haben
sie verkauften auch Produkte die es noch
gar nicht gab
oracle hat viele Futures verkauft man
nimmt eine Menge Geld ein macht Gewinn
mit Dingen die erst noch kommen
und dann stellt sich die Frage wenn du
endlich liefern kannst an wen verkaufst
du es du hast es ja schon jedem verkauft
und zwar drei Jahre bevor du es hattest
und dazu kam dass das neueste Produkt
ein Blindgänger war
Oracle Version 6 war voller
Schwachstellen die Kunden waren
frustriert die Verkäufe brachen ein
insgesamt es wird manchmal als die
nato-erfahrung von Oracle bezeichnet und
das war es auch wir haben kein Fett
abgeschnitten sondern Muskeln und in
einigen Fällen könnte man sogar sagen
wir schnitten ein paketmaßen ab mit dem
freien Fall des Aktienkurses schrumpfte
auch Alisons Vermögen
bis zum 1 November 1990 hatte er 790
Millionen Dollar verloren seine Firma
ein Milliardenprojekt war dabei zu
scheitern
[Musik]
er arbeitete die ganze Zeit daran und
jetzt war er das gespürt es war
furchtbar für ihn
wir sind ein Haufen Kinder die mit dem
Geschäft aufgewachsen sind aber wir
waren keine Kinder mehr und das Geschäft
war kein kleines Geschäft mehr es war
jetzt groß und wir mussten fast die
gesamte Geschäftsleitung ersetzen das
war ein sehr schmerzhafter Prozess er
überzeugte den bekannten Management und
Verkaufsberater Ray Lane in das
Unternehmen einzusteigen
er brachte das mit was ich als operative
Disziplin bezeichnen würde und die
Erfahrung wie ein großes Unternehmen
läuft es war chaotisch schmerzhaft das
wollte keiner noch mal durchmachen
und so wurde irgendwie alles auf Null
gesetzt
der wahre Retter des Unternehmens kam
jedoch in Form eines neuen
produktsack Nelson war der jüngste
Marketingleiter von Oracle Oracle 7 war
ein spektakuläres Produkt field die
Zukunft sah wieder rosig aus und ich
glaube jeder war Oracle wusste dass
damals und konnte ich spüren
es wurde nicht nur schrittweise besser
sondern um ganze Größenordnungen
[Musik]
Firma war der Nahtoderfahrung
ausgewechselt 1994 überstiegen die
Einnahmen von Oracle die zwei Milliarden
Dollar-Marke die Aktien waren fast 3
Milliarden Dollar wert
dafür Alison war das noch lange nicht
genug um das Software Schwergewicht zu
werden musste Alice in den Kampf mit dem
Champion aufnehmen
persönlich enttäuscht zu sein dass er
nicht reicher war als Bill Gates wenn du
nicht die Nummer eins warst wenn du
nicht der reichste warst dann warst du
nicht an der Spitze du warst nicht der
beste Fälle sind verlor
ich denke dass Larry dachte dass er in
einem riesigen Wettbewerb mit Bill Gate
stand
Gates selbst hatte das vielleicht gar
nicht so gesehen aber Larry wollte als
der größte Innovator und Verkäufer in
der Softwarewelt anerkannt werden
und er hatte einen harten Kampf gegen
den Typen der seines Software praktisch
in jeden einzelnen PC der Welt eingebaut
hatte
[Musik]
Allison war auf Gates fixiert später gab
er öffentlich zu Privatdetektive
angestellt zu haben um Schmutz über ihn
auszugraben Gates neues Produkt Windows
95 begeisterte die gesamte Techwelt und
auch Alison bei diesem Auftritt in der
Charlie Rose Show dieses Windows 95 ist
eine enorm komplizierte Software und
dass die Leute das in ihren Haushalten
installieren und managen sollten finde
ich ein bisschen komisch ich meine es
wird Zeit für etwas das leichter zu
bedienen ist das ist Teil unserer
Strategie Microsoft anzugreifen aber es
bringt nichts Darts of Bill Gate zu
werfen oder ihn zu beneiden man muss
über Produkte nachdenken und Produkte
entwickeln die besser sind als die die
Microsoft verkauft
Alison machte einen Schritt in den Markt
für verbrauchergeräte er nannte es den
Netzwerkcomputer oder NC er brachte den
Computer mit großen Getöse auf den Markt
die Computer die wir derzeit herstellen
Personal Computer sind ziemlich teuer
und sehr komplex also haben wir diesen
neuen klassischen Computer eingeführt er
ist sehr leicht kostet sehr wenig jetzt
kann jeder einen Computer benutzen weil
er kostengünstig und leicht zu bedienen
ist wir können im Internet surfen Sie
können E-Mails senden und er sagte er
wird 500 Dollar kosten
sozusagen eine Art Internetgerät nichts
anderes als ihr Toaster ich kann mich an
ein Gespräch mit ihm erinnern indem er
sagte weißt du das Internet macht es
möglich sich auf jedem Desktop eine Welt
ohne Microsoft vorzustellen
und das war die Geburtsstunde des NC
Allison versuchte sein Baby mit einer
Kampagne voranzubringen und machte sich
über den beliebten PC lustig
ich hasse den PC oder stell das Zeug
doch ins Netz
die gehören nicht den Pappe und auf den
Lastwagen und ins Geschäft
und dann muss ich hin und mir das Zeug
holen das ist verrückt
ich liebe das Internet
doch als die pc-preise fielen war auch
der NC zum Scheitern verurteilt
ich glaube nicht dass an der Idee etwas
falsch war ich glaube es war bloß zu
früh fünf Jahre später hätten wir die
Welt erobert
und was haben die PC-Hersteller Dell HP
Gateway gemacht wir haben einen 500
Dollar PC entwickelt der super im
Internet surfen und E-Mails verarbeitet
sein NC war seiner Zeit zu weit voraus
aber seine Vision vom Internet war immer
noch genau richtig
Datenbank wurde zur Grundlage all der
Internetdienste die für uns heute
selbstverständlich sind
experience
die speichern Informationen rufen
Informationen ab und liefern
Informationen über die Oracle Datenbank
für die Leute dachten Larry sei verrückt
jetzt ist er ein geniess und es löste
das größte IT-Problem der Geschichte im
Jahr 2000 gehörte Larry Allisons
Unternehmen zu den
elite-tech-unternehmen der Welt
aber interne Kämpfe verdrängten bald den
Geschäftsführer von Oracle Ray Lane
der zum zweiten Kommandeur und
Thronfolger aufgestiegen war
er beschrieb die Kultur des Unternehmens
das er verlassen hat es reichte nicht
wenn ein Verkäufer seine Quote erfüllte
er musste 200% seiner Quote erfüllen
die obersten zehn Prozent haben
Millionen bekommen und alle anderen fiel
durchs Netz sie sind schwache Soldaten
sagte er passe nicht in das System von
Oracle die einzige Person die dort
Entscheidungen treffe sei Larry
viele bei Oracle waren verwirrt wer das
Sagen hatte und das ist ziemlich
unberechenbar wie eine galaktische
Kollision bei der zwei Sterne
Aufeinandertreffen eine ziemlich heftige
Explosion
Oracle war auf dem Vormarsch hinter
jedoch in einem wichtigen Bereich
hinterher wir kämpfen immer noch um
Relevanz bei den Anwendungen die sind
weltweit die Nummer zwei bei den
Anwendungen Nummer zwei hinter SAP im
ERP-Bereich junge diese zwei wird
langsam alt wir sind Nummer zwei im CRM
hinter der Siebel aber wir wachsen
schneller als SAP und Zwiebel und wir
sind fest entschlossen die Nummer eins
bei den Anwendungen zu werden so wie wir
die Nummer eins bei den Datenbanken sind
um die Nummer eins zu werden musste
Alison etwas tun was er lange vermieden
hatte durch Übernahmen an neue
Technologien zu kommen
als er zu diesem Schluss kam öffnete er
sein Portemonnaie und setzte viel höher
an als jeder andere und der Tat ist viel
schneller als jeder andere
Allison wollte neue Anwendung Software
mit seiner Produktlinie kombinieren
2003 nahm er die Firma people soft bei
einem feindlichen Übernahmeversuch ins
Visier
das Justizministerium verklagte Oracle
aus kartellrechtlichen Gründen eine
Übernahme würde das Unternehmen in die
Lage versetzen die Zinsen rechtswidrig
zu erhöhen nach anderthalbjährigem Kampf
stellten sich die Gerichte auf
oracle-seite Allison kaufte people soft
für 10,3 Milliarden Dollar
es ist sehr selten dass jemand von der
Regierung verklagt wird und dann gewinnt
ich meine das beweist nur wieder wie
hartnäckig dieser Typ ist die meisten
Jungs hätten wohl eher aufgegeben
in den nächsten fünf Jahren gab er fast
34 Milliarden Dollar für den Kauf von 52
Unternehmen aus
Geschäftsführerin des Technologie
Forschungsteams bei der international
strige and investment Group
er schaute sich um und sah wie sich die
Landschaft verändert und wie das
Gemetzel das einigen seiner Konkurrenten
angetan wurde ihm die Möglichkeit für
weitere Übernahmen gab
Legends um Technologie zu kaufen hinter
der er her war Brand er hat wirklich
diesen ganzen M&A Trend in der
tech-branche gesetzt
akquisitionslust steigerte sich 2009 mit
seinem 7,4 Milliarden Dollar schweren
Trophäen Kauf von San Micro Systems dem
führenden Hardware-Unternehmen
2010 richtete er seinen Blick auf eine
ganz andere Trophäe eine jahrzehntelange
400 Millionen Dollar Obsession BMW
Oracal Racing entstand im Jahr 2000 für
Alisons Teilnahme am Americas Cup dem
vielleicht ältesten aktiven Preis im
internationalen Sport doch was Alison
schuf war vollkommen neu
das Boot ist ein Trimaran der zu
fliegenschein
die Ozeane hatten so etwas noch nicht
gesehen
es besteht absolut kein Zweifel dass er
es Hass zu verlieren überhaupt keinen
Zweifel
grand Dalton war im America's Cup gegen
Allison angetreten ich erinnere mich
damals und wir werden ja auch wieder
gegen ihn antreten dieser Mann ist sehr
entschlossen zu gewinnen
am Valentinstag 2010 brachte Alison den
America's Cup zum ersten Mal seit 15
Jahren wieder in die USA
er feierte mit seiner jetzigen Ex-Frau
der Romanautorin Melanie craft
der alte Samurai Krieger tauchte wieder
auf als sein Freund Marc Hurth als CEO
bei Jule Packard zurücktrat es ging um
Vorwürfe der sexuellen Belästigung und
Unregelmäßigkeiten bei
Spesenabrechnungen Allison war entsetzt
und griff den HP Vorstand an
gerade die schlimmste
Personalentscheidung getroffen seit die
apple-idioten Steve Jobs entlassen haben
einen Monat später verblüffte Alison die
Geschäftswelt als er den entlassenen
Manager anstellte
die Seifenoper von Silicon Valley ging
weiter als h.p Leo Apotheker zum CEO
machte sein ehemaliges Unternehmen sAP
ist einer der größten Rivalen von Oracle
die Unternehmen waren in ein
dreijähriges Verfahren wegen
Urheberrechtsverletzung verwickelt das
im November 2010 zu Ende ging
SAP die deutsche Softwarefirma muss
Oracle 1,3 Milliarden Dollar zahlen es
war der größte Vergleich aller Zeiten
für Software-Piraterie mit diesem Schlag
hatte Alison neues Blut auf dem
Schlachtfeld der Informationstechnologie
vergossen und er ist entschlossener denn
je zu gewinnen to win
Allison ist in New Yorker Yankees
ziemlich ähnlich sie sind ein Team das
man liebt oder hasst und als Konkurrent
von Larry Allison weiß ich dass es bei
ihm auch so ist
erfolgreicher war
während die meisten visionäre sich um
Kopf und Kragen reden und sagen oh so
könnte die Welt sein sieht Larry wie die
Welt sein kann und versucht dann auch
sie so zu machen
mit einer 1200 Dollar Beteiligung an
einem kleinen Unternehmen und baute es
durch Willenskraft zu einem der größten
Softwareunternehmen der Welt auf
[Musik]